today we were checking out the Jaguar
Jaguar Jack the problem is they say it
Jaguar I say Jaguar and then I get made
fun of behind me is the Jaguar I pace
this is Jaguars first electric SUV and
we get to test it out today last year my
sister and I went to Austria for the
launch of this SUV and we had so much
fun I got a chance to host the
livestream so if you guys remember this
I love the way he's a Jaguar that's how
we say it you've literally never sounded
more American than being right here in
Austria so let's take it for a drive
[Music]
we're cruising through Fang Academy
right now this is so much fun I actually
have a GoPro up above on the roof and
everyone is holding on these canyon
roads are a little curvy but what's
great is with the regenerative braking
anytime I take my foot off of the pedal
it's breaking for me and that's
regenerating the power so that I'm
actually driving the car
regenerative braking is when the car
slows the energy is created within the
car's braking system in a non electric
vehicle this energy is wasted but in an
electric vehicle that energy can be
captured and used to give the car more
energy for more range on a full charge
you can go 234 miles it also goes zero
to sixty and four point five seconds
with 394 horsepower and let me tell you
what it's so fast the first time I put
my foot to the pedal I was like what I
flattened my sister again oh my god I
love this car so much okay let's let's
no keys push to start it also has a
really great couple
you can get 80% battery charge from
empty and 40 minutes using 100 kilowatt
DC fast charger they're available
nationwide through charging suppliers
like charge point and Evi go for most of
this trip I had been using charge point
the Jaguar I based won three World Car
of the Year awards this is the first
time that this has been done by a single
vehicle oh wow tight squeeze
good thing I'm a compact SUV
[Music]
aerodynamics are so important in an
electric vehicle to maximize the airflow
over the car there's a gap at the top of
the grill for air to enter then a scoop
in the hood for the air to flow up over
the car the air then pulls over the roof
and is directed over the rear spoiler
which has a special peak design for
maximum Aero a fishin see
going on a road trip so the first thing
we need to do is pack up I'm actually
really surprised how much room is in
this thing I was a little concerned
because Jenna and I packed pretty
heavily too much and I have an entire
suitcase dedicated to Maddie the entire
suitcase dedicated to my gear plus but
myself
[Music]
Mattie what you need to see it on you
want one but we're off to San Diego it's
gonna take two enough hours to get there
oh I'm sorry
finally on the road three and a half
hours late my fault I have 213 miles to
go until I need a full charge and it
looks like we have 104 miles until we
get to San Diego which is an hour and 42
minutes traffic doesn't look to be too
bad don't jinx it don't jinx it I have
my air-conditioned seats on right now
it's so crazy I've never had these
before it's like it's really chilling my
body my charges for the first time last
night it was about 75% so it took about
three and a half hours to charge this is
great we've only have to charge the
entire way there we'll just plug it in
at a spa hotel and you're good to go
[Music]
our update for you guys we have 151
miles remaining on discharge but I just
want to see how easy it is to find
someplace in charge so in the maps you
can search along your route to find a
charging station so Jenna just did that
so Jenna hit that first charging station
this is my first time give me some juice
now we charge and walk the dog
[Music]
hi I'm just unplugging my av juice
know your exit that way oh really
it's an entry this is matter this is
enteral middle east exit this is enter
only uh-huh that is under only I know
and told you it told me not to get off
here but it looked like this is where
houses to get off 50 feet towards
California 76 Coast Highway but it's
also cry while you are driving with you
driving your kidnappers yes we are
actually the activation this is turn
right
[Music]
Maddi
are you hungry they gave you a dog bowl
and a plate this is for you eat your
dinner
we finally made it we're staying at the
Fairmont in San Diego and this place is
so beautiful it's The Fairmont Casa Del
Mar and this this is so great look at
this massive and adult oh my gosh it's
so pretty flowers
wait there's shut up oh my goodness
[Music]
[Applause]
it is day two we're still in San Diego
and we're gonna go on a hike now the eye
pace is kicking I am really enjoying
driving this thing so much it really is
so fun but Jenna just went up ahead of
me and we're going on a little hike it
is so nice on the trail I feel bad we
didn't bring Maddie I know I didn't the
dogs would be allowed because usually
they're not allowed guess what we messed
up
[Music]
have you arrived make me keep billing
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh there's a ladder
[Music]
probably dilemmas going one hand
available
[Music]
going to see the sunset I lost the car
keys so Jenna ran ahead of me yeah
looking good
we have so much fun this property is
incredible hey Maddie had the best time
oh yeah the car is here now the real
test is is it charged to 100% this is
great it's officially 100% charged and
now we're gonna head home look at that
we have 248 miles to go back to Los
Angeles so here's a really exciting
update I'm about to go hiking and there
was no parking anywhere all of the lots
were full except for this wonderful spot
it says I could park here because I'm
Evy and it just so happens I need to get
charged up
Maddie do you love Evy lifestyle Evie
thank you
oh no he's getting stuck on the bull
horns he had to potty really badly